avec toi dépôts d'ubs au nom cyril
hanouna passes ont trouvé tout de suite
pour un nouvel épisode de touche pas à
mon poste avec toute l'équipe de la
vérité si je travaille bien toute
l'équipe est là bas c'est pourri après
on n'est pas prêt
[Musique]
josé qui est le [ __ ] qu'est plus
dragueur de l'équipe la vérité qui est
plus dragueur de l'équipe on va parler
du soldat qui est vraiment sur le marché
énorme mais ça va s'affoler cci batteur
richard tu te comportes comme un mec
veut la mairie cherche ça peut être oui
mais justement à pau est célibataire
série second surtout pas mais enfin bon
passons à besson ça sent la fin sans la
vérité qui mais faute de temps pour
tourner une scène de temps pour tourner
même si quand on est cinq tout le temps
c'est c'est le groupe c'est l'inertie de
groupe ils appellent ça des châssis
groupe servier refuse pas je fais ça
l'inertie groupe oui le groupe fois
c'est richard la vérité qui est le mieux
payé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes c'est pas mal de costumes la
bataille en chine
par ailleurs il est bon tout comme s'il
en pleuvait non mais ça ça a été fait
j'ai démonté après déjà parce qu'au
pressing s'est achevée en musique mais
si vous me choque c'est vrai que c'est
dommage
kesha j'ai vu ce vous soulevez un peu
parce que vous êtes voilà merci ça parce
qu'elle au siège de richard qui est beau
il est écrasé par les chez richard
thériault on attendait c'était les
matches au mois de mai
vous me demandez les chats je serai
toujours là quoi le problème avec je
raconte au téléspectateur ya stéphane
bern qui tourne juste à côté comment ça
va bien je pense qu'on va aller faire un
petit tour sur son plateau un pour lui
dire un petit bonjour pour lui faire un
petit gars là ils sont venus en france
et je vais vous faire un petit gars là
sur cette caméra parce que vous êtes le
champion du monde du gala m non mais
avec tout le monde
le maître galaxie vos meilleurs ou non
aller avec tout le monde allait d'accord
avec tout le monde gilbert
mais attention
[Rires]
on va l'empêcher stéphane bern
c'est important d'aller le voir une
victoire est possible
heureusement cyril hanouna encore
non
ah ah
la peine
oh la la
[Applaudissements]
on n'allait pas
taiana à la réputation n'est pas ça ne
leur fait plus jamais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
paris qu est ce que tu m'en donnes vert
avant que les gens pensent que ce soit
un petit ya la halle à stefan seul fait
pas payer
yala contre cours la semaine prochaine
mon boss de toute l'équipe
merci aux élèves ce motion
[Musique]